one of the most anticipated debates in
the 2022 election cycle was last night
it was quack television Dr Mehmet Oz
against Democratic Pennsylvania
Lieutenant Governor John fetterman they
are vying to be the next senator from
Pennsylvania
now I am not going to sugarcoat this for
anybody and I didn't during yesterday's
much watched live stream John fetterman
suffered a stroke some months ago
he is recovering and has been cleared by
his doctors to say you can serve as
Senator he is not struggling cognitively
in the sense of memory
logic critical thinking but fetterman is
struggling significantly when it comes
to
um speaking and translating thought into
speech it's really sad to see and
what is horrifying is that the
completely unqualified
delusional and incompetent Mehmet Oz
may become a senator
because John fetterman had a stroke
and didn't perform particularly well
last night it was difficult to watch I'm
putting politics aside here for a second
I feel terribly for John fetterman
public figure in the middle of a
campaign has a stroke running for an
important office
and now visibly struggles to speak
needed closed captioning during
yesterday's debate
um in order to uh better understand the
subject matter having having trouble
with audit auditory processing
um I hope for the absolute best for
fetterman's recovery and it was a very
difficult debate to watch last night by
the way fetterman was not a particularly
good debater I mean fetterman was the
best candidate in the Democratic primary
but even at the Democratic primary
debates he wasn't the best debater let's
look at a few clips from last night the
most disturbing clip was when memet Oz
said that local political leaders should
be the ones making decisions along with
patients and doctors about abortion no
they shouldn't it should be doctors and
patients but here is Oz with a very
extreme statement there should not be
involvement from the federal government
and how States decide their abortion
decisions as a physician I've been in
the room when there's some difficult
conversations happening I don't want the
federal government involved with that at
all I want women doctors local political
leaders letting the Democracy that's
always allowed our nation to thrive to
put the best ideas forward so why do we
need politicians in the room why is it
better if their low local this idea of
let the states decide when there really
aren't differences like let me give you
an example when it comes to gun safety
as an example Bernie Sanders is correct
that gun ownership in Vermont is a very
different thing socio-culturally than it
is in I don't know North Carolina
and so
regardless of your views I can
understand why one would say well
because gun ownership in Vermont is a
different thing than in North Carolina
maybe there should be a different
conversation happening in each state it
doesn't mean we don't have gun safety
regulations or that I think we shouldn't
have them but it's at least plausible
when it comes to abortion it's
fundamentally about this is a medical
procedure and this is a procedure in
which you shouldn't have politicians in
the middle why is it better to have a
local
of you know a governor or a mayor
telling women what they can't do rather
than a senator in DC either way it's bad
and this is a completely outrageous and
extreme position here is just a clip
just to really sum up the difference in
the positions between Mehmet Oz and John
fetterman on this issue all I want women
doctors local political leaders letting
the Democracy that's always allowed our
nation to thrive to put the best ideas
forward so states can decide for
themselves contrast that with my
opponent John fetterman but if you
believe that the choice for abortion
belongs between you and your doctor
that's what I fight for it's it's that
that's it's that simple it's that simple
and Oz's position of course has been
cobbled together in trying to basically
focus group the best possible thing to
say exceptions but not this and no
federal involvement but let local it's a
mess and it's outrageous and it's
extreme the fetterman position is the
correct position now John fetterman did
comment on his stroke and he had the
following to say about it
here's a man that spent more than 20
million dollars of his own money to try
to buy that seat
um also having to talk about something
called the Oz rule that if he's on TV
he's lying he did that during his career
on his TV show he's done that during his
campaign about lying about
our record here and he's also lying
probably during this debate and let's
also talk about the elephant in the room
I had a stroke he's never let me forget
that
and I might miss some words during this
debate mush two words together but it
knocked me down but I'm going to keep
coming back up and this campaign is all
about to me is about fighting for
everyone in Pennsylvania they've ever
gotten
up that needs to get back up and
fighting for all forgotten communities
all across Pennsylvania that also got
knocked down that needs to keep
Pennsylvania yeah so as you can see
um
it it takes a lot of courage to do what
fetterman did last night
it it's he's in the middle of a recovery
from a stroke and uh he brought it up
and it was really something to see and
also quite difficult to watch the issue
of the quack cures promoted by Mehmet Oz
on his program came up yesterday and
listened very carefully to the exact
language that Oz uses and you will very
quickly see why he's choosing such
narrow language Mr Oz you have built a
lucrative career around medicine but
you've been criticized even by some
fellow Physicians for promoting quote
unproven ill-advised and at times
potentially dangerous treatments what is
your response to that you have 60
seconds
did you or your company make a profit
from promoting those products I never
sold weight loss products as as
described in those commercials it's a
it's a television show like this is a
television show so people can run
commercials on the shows and that's a
perfectly appropriate and very
transparent process
I never consider the language there okay
I never sold
weight loss products
as described in John fetterman's
commercials
okay that is extraordinarily narrow
language he provided a platform
for those products
it made the show profitable
he was promoting green coffee extract as
a magical weight loss cure that is not
evidence-based he was promoting
raspberry ketones as the quote number
one miracle in a bottle to burn your fat
that is not evidence-based he promoted
guests who say Homeopathy works
uncritically and I know some people in
my audience get mad about this it
doesn't work guys I'm sorry I know
people email me every time there are no
active ingredients in Homeopathy there
are no measurable active ingredients it
does not work it has been widely studied
oh but David big Pharma won't allow
studies guys Homeopathy has been widely
studied it doesn't work and Oz promoted
it so extraordinarily narrow language
there Oz also promoting medication
supposedly for colds uh the way to get
rid of a cold is to wait five to seven
days okay no matter what you take during
those five to seven days right coffee
enema which is dangerous by the way uh
uh you know fried plantains
um baths with uh
whatever you know coconut oil bath
five to seven days later the cold will
be gone and to attribute it to all of
these different supposed cold cures
doesn't actually make any sense so
bottom line the question with this race
is what happens with the polling what
happens with the polling at this point
in time because going into yesterday's
debate the polling is what it is right
now fetterman plus 1.3
veteran plus 1.3 and is if you take a
look you will see that fetterman had a
nearly nine point lead in early August
and that lead was only six at the
beginning of September and that lead was
only four towards the end of September
and that lead is now 1.3 how much of an
impact can a single debate have on a
race like this particularly when one
candidate is visibly struggling with his
speech as a result of the stroke that he
had I don't have the answer but we'll
find out in the next seven to ten days
and listen the election's only two weeks
away and then we'll know a lot more
the David packman shows longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers I've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books I read I
love reading I read all the time but
there's even more books I don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
blinkist connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users I have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist Sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to Robert Greene's the 48 Laws of Power
the new version Robert Greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com davidpakman
the link is down below